la france va muscler sa cyber défense
qui va prendre un tour plus percutant la
loi de programmation militaire 2019 2025
on avait fait une priorité mais le cadre
manqué de souplesse pour entrer par la
grande porte dans la guerre
informationnelle alors la ministre des
armées florence parly vient de présenter
la doctrine militaire de lutte
informatique d' influence nommé l21 elle
propose un cadre pour contrer les
menaces exponentielle dans l'ère des
médias sociaux on écoute florence parly
la lutte informatique d' influence
cela désigne l'ensemble des opérations
militaires
conduites en appui de nos forces dans le
champ informationnel pour détecter
caractérisée contre et des attaques ou
appuyer la communication stratégiques
associées à une opération alors que
contient cette aile 21 elle détaille les
moyens pour se défendre dans le
cyberespace contre le terrorisme ou la
manipulation d'état à visées hostiles
contrer les attaques informationnelles
adverse s'opposant à l'action de nos
forces pour les faire cesser ou en
atténuer les effets dénoncer les
incohérences ou mensonge de l'adversaire
promouvoir l'action des forces armées
sur les médias sociaux mais comment
faire jeu égal avec les autres
puissances qui selon florence parly ne
rechigne pas se servir de l'information
fausse manipulée ou subvertit comme
d'une arme la france va se doter de
nouveaux réflexes tout du moins
officiellement dénoncée contenir
affaiblir ou discrédités y compris par
la ruse une attaques informationnelles
un dur adversaire en erreur ou encore
approuvé les opérations menées dans le
champ physique par des manoeuvres de
déception c'est à dire de dissimulation
ou de tromperie utiliser légalement la
ruse le mensonge sur internet même pour
contenir une attaque est tout de même
une vraie rupture épistémologique pour
la france un saut en avant qui avait
déjà été franchie avec pertes et fracas
en 2020 facebook avait détecté des
comportements inappropriés coordonnées
sur son réseau concernant des
communautés en république centrafricaine
et au mali faux profils aux photos vous
et même vidéo insultante certains
provenaient d'individus russes liés à
une société de mercenaires d'autres
d'individus français au coude à coude
pour vanter leur influence positive dans
la région les deux groupes rivaux ont
fini par s'affronter directement dans
des espaces de discussion s'accusant
mutuellement de propager des flics news
la france jouant les facs checkers en
décembre le rapport grafika et
l'internet observatory de stanford ont
épinglé cet état de fait en créant des
faux comptes et des fausses pas gentil
fightnews pour combattre les trolls elle
les intervenants français ont perpétué
et implicitement justifié le
comportement problématique qu'ils
entendaient combattre de guerre lasse
les français vont officiellement utilisé
des armes déloyales pour disposer des
mêmes que tout le monde sinon c'est pas
du jeu et aujourd'hui l'armée va assumer
pressé par la nécessité d'utiliser les
tactiques qu'elles dénonçaient il ya peu
chez ses adversaires mais en conservant
des garde-fous assure florence parly les
armées françaises ne déstabiliseront pas
un état étranger à travers des actions
informationnel qui viserait par exemple
ses processus électoraux les équipes de
cyberdéfense engagement en outre à
respecter le droit national et
international notamment la charte des
nations unies ainsi que les règles du
droit international humanitaire 1
milliard 600 millions d'euros sera
consacré à la cyber défense de la france
entre 2019 et 2025 l'armée souhaite des
recrues experte en langue rare encodage
en psychologie le ministère va embaucher
environ 800 cyber défenseur en plus des
1100 déjà prévu à troller c'est un sport
de riche